the F-16 Fighting Falcon is a very agile
Modern Combat uh aircraft his first
customer was uh took delivery in 1979
but it's been continuously upgraded ever
since that time it's a 1500 mile an hour
Mark II fighter with a 20 millimeter
cannon and has stations underneath the
wings and the center for a full range of
air to wear and air to ground missiles I
was privileged enough to fly one many
years ago it was a potentially very
powerful very agile and very capable but
crucially this aircraft was made by the
Americans therefore the Americans needed
to provide permission for an export or
gifting of the platform to Ukraine and
at the G7 conference President Biden
gave the green light for that capability
but who operates this airplane there are
over 5000 of these Platforms in service
all the way around the world uh it's the
most widely exported aircraft the US is
the largest customer but they've also
been exported through Europe to Israel
and the Middle East but some are being
retired because in favor of the F-35 The
Joint Strike Fighter and if we look at
Europa own and Norway their Fleet of 64
f-16s has already been retired last year
and the Dutch are getting rid of 24 in
the very near future that might provide
a pool of aircraft for the ukrainians
but when are these going to actually
appear in Ukraine presidents lensky will
want them to appear as soon as possible
but the harsh reality is despite
American efforts to condense the flying
training course experience Ukrainian
Pilots will still take about four months
to complete the course they will not
appear in in the theater anytime this
year likewise the aircraft has been
around for 45 years they have lots of
different software standards and
Hardware standards in service Ukraine
will need a common fleet but let's not
distract from the fact that this is a
major significant development President
Putin will have it judged that over time
Western appetite for the conflicts in
Ukraine would would Wane but this
commitment by the International
Community to provide f-16s to give
Ukraine its own combat air capability
over the long term will prove a grave
concern for President Putin